so romantic he got down on both knees
and he said oh you got down on both
knees she was like I figured one was not
enough I gotta go to the full begging
position you know and plead for her hand
Wow young in that clip 10 years later
because you're creeping up on your 10
year anniversary what is the secret to
making this thing work
Oh God I think the good part is that
does it feel like 10 years honestly and
it feels like it was just yesterday that
we were you know we were planning our
wedding and doing the special and the
whole thing and then we three kids it
kind of just flies by it does what
people may not know or may not remember
is you were an ET correspondent this was
your home so really you come back you
are my buddy
yes what do you remember out your days
on ET sitting down with George Clooney
talking about his newest movie and he's
talking about my expose inert it was an
ad I'm like we're cool that crazy fat
suit do you look great then and I'm like
he remembered me you guys kinda also
meant on a video shoot right I never got
paid for that video you never got paid
somebody asked me how much you don't
make for that minute I've been paying
every day since the budget I was gonna
say hold on we have a love he'll buy
four back I mean at least for 24 hours
yeah Hornet on thick I was few ladies if
you know what you want go so now all
these years later you guys have a new
show it's called love is blind here you
will choose someone to marry without
ever seeing it's a different kind of
social experiment yeah explain 5950
women separated you put on the other
side of a wall from someone you cannot
see but you have to get to know them and
and learn about them purely by talking
it's like the old school way of dating
so you only see that person that you've
created this connection with once you've
proposed to them and they've accepted
looks fantastic I cannot wait for
everyone to see this show thank you
Kevin
[Music]